hola qué tal muy buen día nuevamente se
ha tratado esta reunión con bastante
discreción al igual que la pasada del 5
de marzo cuando no fue previamente
anunciada a medios de comunicación se
pudo conocer que estarían en venezuela y
en historia embajador de eeuu y también
roger cartes quien es el enviado
presidencial especial para asuntos de
rehenes lo dijo públicamente nicolás
maduro quien confirmó en horas de la
noche que esa delegación estaba en eeuu
y estaba reunida con jorge rodríguez
quien es presidente de la asamblea
nacional pero también es el delegado de
nicolás maduro en las conversaciones con
la oposición en el diálogo que se
intenta reanudar en mexico de que se
pudiera estar hablando bueno es
especulado que se continuaría con las
conversaciones del pasado 5 de marzo en
el que estaba presente el tema
energético también la liberación de
rehenes recordemos que en territorio
venezolano continúa un grupo de
ciudadanos estadounidenses detenidos y
nuevo la pasada reunión del 5 de marzo
se pudo conocer la liberación de de
ellos también estaría presente la
reanudación del diálogo entre la
oposición de nicolás maduro y el
gobierno venezolano que intentan como te
decía renovar este diálogo en mexico y
hasta el momento eso no se ha
materializado
daniela también maduro y un llamado a
las empresas francesas para que
inviertan en el sector del petróleo y el
gas que hay sobre esto
si lo dijo nicolás maduro le respondió
directamente al presidente francés el
manual macro en que inició la propuesta
de que tanto venezuela como irán
pudiesen nuevamente entrar al mercado
recordemos que ambos países están
sancionados por eeuu y sería para
reactivar la producción tanto de
petróleo como de gas intentar controlar
frenar el alza de los precios también le
quería agregar que con respecto a la
pregunta anterior que france24 pudo
confirmar de manera independiente que
también una reunión entre nico entre
james story y juan guaidó recordemos que
juan guaidó es considerado como
presidente interino de venezuela por
parte del gobierno de eeuu